you know which has been around a hundred
years and is a vastly you know
fast-growing industry but what we wanted
to do was to turn product placement into
a true advertising medium and allow us
to be able to integrate brands into
popular entertainment content at scale
anywhere in the world on demand and this
was to solve a particular problem which
is you know just make a making a much
better experience for audiences who are
you know really struggling with the
volume and the nature of some of the
advertising they have to endure in
between the shows that you know
interrupting the shows they love to
watch thinking behind the floatation
well our customers are the biggest media
businesses on the planet now I'm talking
about companies like Alibaba you know
recently acquired a business in China
which is the equivalent of China's
YouTube RTL group who owned Fremantle
who make shows like Got Talent and
x-factor and and companies like this
these are very large organizations and
we are a new innovative technology
business so in order to have the
credibility to work with these kinds of
businesses in in the largest advertising
markets in the world we felt this was
the best way to go it was not a
condition you had a big funding round
last year this what this flotation is in
the condition of that or anything no no
not at all but we are we're right at the
point where we're scaling you know it's
taken us a long time to develop this
technology it's very sophisticated we're
deploying it in these very large
customers and in order to do that you
need the credibility and the resilience
and the stamina that comes through a
flotation like this now you've got
clients all over the world as we're
saying US Brazil China not that many in
the UK where you're headquartered well
because we focused on the largest
fastest growing ad markets in the world
and also the biggest bigoted video
consumption market so you know you go to
a market like China you've got an
enormous population with billions of
consumers who are you know watching
videos like never before so given that
we have limited resources to some extent
we can't tackle every market in the
world we've just gone for the very big
one so in North America Brazil China but
I'm sure the UK will come along in time
I very very briefly what's your favorite
TV advert around this because you know I
like the Martin Freeman
where they all get snow I tell you the
the the Vodafone story you know the love
story I just like Martin Freeman
well-known safe ice Martin Freeman who
criticizes capitalism regularly of
course well it also benefits from it
tremendously at the same time but it
just is such an endearing character I
think all right good to see you good to
see you thanks a lot